how did Chris Hemsworth
get casters thought I auditioned for
Thor many years ago probably 11 12 years
ago and
um I didn't get a call back
um
I think my audition sucked I think that
was that was the response I got and then
my younger brother auditioned and he got
very close he got down to the last five
people and uh and then didn't get it and
they were like look he's great but he's
a bit Young
my manager then said well he does have
an older brother which was me I came
back in re-auditioned a few times and
just had a different attitude maybe I
had a little a little more sort of
motivation that my little brother had
got to look in and I hadn't I also had
done a couple of films in between those
two auditions so I had a bit more
experience and confidence in in what I
was going to do yeah I was I was so
excited
um I had a very slight hesitation about
it was going to be a six picture deal
and did I want to be locked in and
Typecast as one character and I was like
you don't have a choice so shut up and I
pushed that that voice aside and said
yep